foreign
T joins us up next in Denver Colorado
art welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call guys sure
how you doing
I'm doing well so
after doing your baby steps I'm on step
four invest 15 and I've been there for a
few months I don't plan on having
children and I don't have a comb I was
curious what your thoughts are about
living a digital Nomad lifestyle I live
I work a remote job
and uh do pretty well for myself I have
no debt and I don't really know where to
go from here I want to
become more mobile
I currently live in a on my uncle's
property with a very cheap rent and
could easily pay this and just leave my
stuff here instead of have to get rid of
everything
so what are the downsides of not buying
real estate in the market right now and
kind of living my childhood dream and
waiting
uh I don't I don't hear any downsides
you know because yeah but that sounds
too good to be true what's too good
about it to be true
lots of people do it
yeah I know is your plan now you gotta
have a plan are you gonna live in an RV
a camper how are you gonna travel I have
a
like I said I have no debt I've got
about 12 Grand to throw at
go into to do the camper thing without
touching my emergency funds okay
and
I don't know I'm kind of hesitant to
pull the trigger because I've been
trying to live frugally these past few
years and get out of the hole that I did
that I dug in my 20s right but are you
saying 12 Grand is going to pay cash for
something or is that
ideally or I have access to personal
interest-free loans from uh we're not
doing that no no no no no no no no no
we're not going to recommend it why'd
you get out of debt in the first place
if you're going to get back into it
yeah say that's kind of what I'm
thinking okay so if we take that off
your table he really wants to go for it
all right we're on the same page now so
how much do you make doing this remote I
make about 85 000 a year so how long
would it take for you to save up the
actual full cost of 40 grand for a good
camper
yeah I would say I could do it by late
next year well there you go if I
buttoned up and and really I think you
can get better than that you said you
have almost no expenses
that's correct so how long would it take
to save up 30 make an 85 with very
little expenses
um
not that long but I'm I'm
scared of debt now that I've gotten out
of it and so we're not I just want to
take it slow okay but again we're not
encouraging we're not encouraging debt
George is just saying how much quicker
could you make the thirty thousand maybe
what I'm saying is how you know out of
your paychecks could you take two or
three grand and put it in a high yield
savings account every single month
yes that puts you at another 30 grand
add it to the 12. and and that gets you
a 42 000 RV camper and now
we just travel and you live that dream
and you continue to do it debt-free you
have a paycheck coming in from the
remote job you need to make sure you
have internet access and uh some people
are doing you know they have internet
access from the camper at all times you
can look into those options as well
so what's the I think the the truth is
it sounds like there's some fear around
jumping into this digital Nomad
lifestyle have you talked to someone
who's done it
uh no I haven't I've been taking Dave's
advice and talking to the old rich
people that I know because that's who I
want to be we'll also jump into the
those communities online and go hey I'm
new to this what are some things I need
to look out for go jump onto some
Facebook groups some Reddit threads and
see what people are saying about this
lifestyle the UPS the Downs The Good the
Bad and uh and then you can jump in
knowing exactly what to expect
okay and guess what happens I'm three
years from now if you hate this and you
go you know what I want to settle down I
want to sleep in the same bed every day
you can just stop and decide to do
something different
it's not the rest of your life don't
don't take on more debt even if it's
interest-free just be patient is let me
ask you a question is the dream does the
dream include you driving the camper or
dragging it behind you or is the dream I
want to go here for three days and then
if I feel like going somewhere else for
four days is it a combo or is the camper
and the RV thing a big part of this
dream
it's really just going I just don't like
looking out the window and seeing the
same thing every day okay I had a hunch
that that was the case and so uh now
that I know that I wouldn't touch the
camper with a 10-foot pole unless you
were into that kind of thing because
that's a asset that is going to go down
it's going to depreciate very very
quickly into George's point if you get
out on this digital Nomad thing and I
just want to go and then I've bought
this thing that's that's depreciating
then that's a pain in the neck down the
road if I change my mind versus you're
debt free you got a good amount of cash
saved up you can save up even more and
if and if you just decide I'm gonna
drive
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna buy a real
gas Friendly Car uh or if you've already
got one a very dependable car I'm gonna
drive here and then I'm gonna drive
there or if you can afford to I'm Gonna
Fly here and then I'll fly there if it's
about moving around
and and you can do your work from
anywhere then this is you coming up with
a budget and a plan to go all right
since I don't have rent anymore and I
know what my income is and if I look at
okay and George you're the king of this
so like budget friendly hotels so if I
find a chain and I become a frequent
rewards person and I'm paying cash for
the hotel rooms and I'm going all right
I couldn't pay this and so I've got a
budget of and so I know what my hotel
and my food cost and and if I'm flying
versus driving this is just putting all
that together and going okay this is
what it looks like and if I can only do
it 20 days a month based on those
financial realities I know I'm living
with my uncle the other 10 days
but I would stay away from the camper in
the RV knowing what I know now
what do you think art
okay I think that's more reasonable I
guess I'm really more afraid of not
having all my stuff that I've always had
what's done
well I mean I've never not stayed in a
house for more than like 10 12 days at a
time then here's the idea first of all
you already said you could store your
stuff with Uncle all right that's one
option but the other option is before we
commit to this full time why don't we
just try this a week at a time for the
next three months what if we take the
next three months and for one week we
try this new lifestyle
and we just sit back and go huh
I always wondered what it was like now
I'm going to test it without committing
full-time yeah
how old are you are okay I'm 31. okay
yeah I like testing this
I just think you need to take the
pressure off of yourself as if you step
into this and this has to be your life
for the next 40 years regardless of what
happens
okay I think that's where my stress is
coming from like what if I don't like it
once I get out there so here's a great
pick up in the car first yeah and then
make sure that that works yeah try that
whole hotel thing yeah especially
responsibly that's it try it on a mini
level right we're gonna mini commit to
this thing we're gonna test it and then
the testing is going to clarify all of
this for you and you're gonna go ding
ding ding or and you might realize you
know what this ain't for me that's right
and that's okay you might just go I need
to travel at least once a month and have
a trip to look forward to and that's
good enough for me yeah but as long as
you do it debt free there's no there's
no need to stress about the no stability
of going into debt if you just say I'm
just a guy who doesn't go into debt I'm
not going to do interest-free loans I'm
not going to owe anyone anything I'm
going to use my debit card I'm going to
pay cash for the RV I'm going to have an
emergency fund for all the expenses
involved with this and I know what to
expect so jump into those communities
ask those types of questions they're
always happy to talk about it and share
their experiences even share their
numbers if here's what the actual cost
is I thought it was going to be
basically living for free turns out it's
seven thousand dollars a month if you
want to do it big and so get do your
homework do the research but I don't see
any issue with you jumping into this